good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy first tuesday in may
welcome to the met gala
extravaganza with your hosts claudia and
jackie oh morning toast original recipe
yes i am here for people listening on
the podcast happy to get awarded yeah uh
good luck trying for the rest of the
show i have been so enrapt in the
mcallen you have been quaking shooketh
obsessed wrapped up in the met gala i
got i was really like looking forward to
it i was telling you that yesterday like
i'm just looking forward to like sitting
on my couch and judging um but i just
didn't see me getting so invested in the
whole thing
and from you know of course the outfits
to the dueling live streams like i have
so many thoughts first on how he like
completely dropped the ball maybe one of
their worst pre-shows ever why
it ended before the kardashians showed
up and i guess that's like a cable
restriction the kardashians were like
whatever like fix it fix it two do you
know how many people they got wrong
they're well everyone thought this guy
fredrick robertson was jared letos that
wasn't their fault they didn't know who
venus williams was they couldn't name
the designer and lo even i know that she
had a whole room at the met like they
were there was no research done and it
was just they had this like household
was it the hosts the producers and
everyone how do you not know anne lowe
like i literally watched one tick talk
about like the the met um
exhibit yeah and i learned who anne lowe
was she was an amazing black designer
who got no recognition so now she's
getting recognition she made jackie o's
wedding dress so they were talking about
like the inspiration of this woman they
gave her a story and they know her name
which is just like disrespectful yeah um
and they had this like hologram machine
which was like their claim to fame you
know they always have like weird tech
sometimes it's good of course the glam
cam comes to mind but like every time
manny cam was a low for society i
completely agree with the magic what we
need more of
your fingers walking
um so they have this every time someone
knew would show up they'd like get a
hologram of them in the studio and like
zanna roberts would like talk about the
meaning and it just like wasn't that
cool and they were so delayed like
vanessa hudgins being the first one
there because she hosted part of the
vogue stream was the best thing that
ever happened to her because she
literally was on the e stream
for two hours vanessa hutchins just hit
the carpet really i saw her on twitter
literally three hours ago
so it was just not premium maybe they
didn't get like premium footage i don't
know it was bad okay i guess we're gonna
just jump right in to matt gala no so
we're gonna go first story is our lukes
everything we're gonna go through
everyone i was so busy last night i
haven't really had a chance i've been
looking this morning but like to really
ruminate so i'm gonna be making some
decisions on the spot about best and
worst looks and i'm really excited to
look through everything but
uh it was zack's birthday last night so
we went out to dinner plus i was
powering through this book for the
redheads and i just have to say
i'm kind of loving it i saw your
instagram it took a turn for the better
and like there's definitely issues with
the book like it's extremely verbose
it's not that really well written but
like the love story is like really a
slow burning
the build up like there's so many
conversations that eventually lead to
them getting together i hate when in
books it's like we went from enemies to
lovers in like two scenes agreed it's
taking like months and it's the payoff
i'm at 80 and i'm so excited to finish
it today oh good
i'm really uh i didn't see that for
myself like when i would first started
it like yesterday i would have rated it
a two today it's creeping up on a four
wow isn't that crazy
so i was really busy with that last
night and i didn't get a chance to like
be the met gala stalker but i am really
excited to go through all the looks even
this morning i've seen some that i
didn't see last night and i'm just i'm
pleasantly surprised uh and we'll go
through also i need to like talk
everything through in order to show how
i feel agreed completely even though
like some of my best and some of my
worst are immediately coming to mind and
i do feel like since you've been you
know on the horn all night like you
might have some of the
history and references that i don't have
yes for some of them and i just wanted
to give a preface thank you for saying
that like before we dive in like first
of all we are not making fun of anyone
personally we're just talking about
clothing and you cannot get offended and
if you get an invitation to the gala
like you are fair game agreed and we're
not making fun of you we're making fun
of your clothes huge you know you likely
had no saying very important yes
and the other thing i wanted to say was
i i know a little bit about like
i might say something's not on theme but
then like you know an art history major
would tell me that it is on theme this
is my knowledge to my knowledge um
and yes thank you that's my disclaimer
before the show when the art history
majors come in and show us how it's on
denum i do see it but for the lay person
we should be able to see that
something's on theme without needing a
degree in art history from wesleyan i
completely completely those are my
favorite looks where it's like the art
history majors appreciate it the lay
person appreciates it and it's nice to
look at and as a lay person i'm feeling
very late
you know we are the lay people
um also just like for from for the met
gala as a whole before we dive into the
looks i thought it was such an
interesting evening because i always
feel like the after party looks are like
such a moment and i woke up this morning
and i had to like search hard for them i
didn't really see a lot of that i
haven't seen one i forgot that that even
happened i know and like kim have an
after-party look i didn't see i saw
kendall did i didn't see kylie i saw
haley bieber i saw billy eilish
um
yeah
i feel like the after parties weren't as
like bustling or just hasn't come out
yet like maybe they're still partying
maybe probably not but
i totally forgot that that was a thing
right no and they're usually like fun
because they don't have to stick to the
theme and it's just like fun out club
fashion or it's like the look i almost
wore but i know for kim and kylie in the
past it's like i wasn't sure which one i
was going to wear to what so it's cool
to see what else they were working on
yeah but i didn't see like a ton of
footage i just thought that was
interesting that is interesting we were
on page six this morning and there was
nothing right except for like kim's
personal after party kim literally could
be an entire episode today there's so
much to unpack it's also just crazy how
first of all they were the dead last
people on the carpet and the carpet is
so chaotic and part of the reason i like
watching the stream and i ended up
switching to vogue which was very good
um is because everyone's really equal at
the met gala like no matter how famous
you are you have to wait in line and
even on the carpet there's like six or
seven spots that you go to to get
photographed and okay let's let's say
you go to spot one and then you're
moving to spot two but someone is still
doing their photos in spot two you like
as an a-lister have to like take a step
back and you're in the background of all
the pictures just kind of waiting and
it's awkward and it's like very humbling
for all these celebrities who you know
don't miss step ever so my favorite part
of watching the live stream was seeing
like all the
celebrities having to act like real
people in the background like waiting in
line um having trouble getting up the
stairs waiting for someone to pass and
then when kim and pete came there was
not one human being on the carpet when
like even the biggest celebrities who
came there must have been like
10 people on the carpet handlers
publicists photographers other
celebrities kim and pete had it all to
themselves and then the stream ended it
was just so crazy how she went from
being first of all her first met gala
like the memes the givenchy like the
couch everyone hated it um to literally
like the party don't start till kim
walks in yeah and i was thinking how
emma chamberlain literally got there at
six o'clock and kim rolled in at 9 30
and it's like what are all these people
doing inside is it like cocktail hour
yeah i'm sure pictures mulling about
checking out the exhibit if i were
going to the macau but i'm not kim
kardashian like it's actually behooves
you to get there earlier because then
people see your look
so many times while waiting to see
everybody else's that they age fondly in
my mind like vanessa hudgens yeah if she
had just been with the rest of the pack
i would barely have noticed her but now
i was forced to look at her dress so
many times that it really grew on me and
that always happens with emma
chamberlain she's a very prompt girly
well she's prompt because she's always
like hosting she was the vogue last year
and this year instagram or tic toc live
stream doing double duty and i always
wind up loving her look because i've
seen it so many times yes i was actually
talking to a friend of mine yesterday
who is a publicist and she was basically
explaining how like unless you're pete
and kim if you get there at the very end
like the public the photographers have
been there all day like they are
uploading like many times throughout the
night that's how we get photos so fast
like if you're at the very end like
they're done like they go home they have
dinner they take a shower and like then
they upload your photos and you're very
much like an afterthought so the timing
even though it sucks to get there early
because you're mulling about for three
hours you really do get so much more
coverage like if you're a thirst monster
yeah if you need a thirst and it's like
not clear how much coverage you're gonna
get like for kim and pete they would
wait all night but yep then i also felt
like people in the middle who aren't
major major stars or didn't have major
looks like really got lost like for me
who comes to mind is someone who got
like totally lost is elizabeth j
is that her name pam and tommy
lily james lily james maybe elizabeth is
her real name um she was like she's one
of my favorites in like the last year
and she just got totally like yeah i
didn't see her till this morning right
she was just another girl in a sparkly
dress yeah there was a lot of that but i
think that's what signifies a good
macabre there's an abundance of glitz
and glamour that people are just very
middle of the pack i mean last year
anybody who showed up would have gotten
photographed because 10 people showed up
but i thought this was super a-list
obviously all the kardashians being
there was a huge moment but we did miss
we didn't have taylor there was a lot of
speculation wouldn't have beyonce
wouldn't have ariana grande rihanna we
didn't have rihanna um so all the
kardashians being there like i do feel
made up for a little bit of the lack of
a-listers elon musk was there like it
was pretty um
i was pretty sure it was pretty a-list
it was pretty a-list except like
anything but take away the kardashians
for one second not so weightless no not
at all but
i mean maybe they'll upload stuff from
inside but we didn't get that many
full sister moments no we got all the
sisters except for
kim and we got a kendall and kylie yes
double trouble yes what's that movie
called it takes two that's what everyone
was sending yeah with the hat yeah
moment also i wanted to just make one
more um shout out
because even though i thought her outfit
was offensively offensively heinous
lala anthony i was so confused i'm like
lala on the vogue stream that's like so
random
i was so wrong first of all let me tell
you why one totally forgot trl queen
like she's interviewed literally every
celebrity ever so her hosting abilities
were amazing and also she so runs in
like such a famous crowd she knows
everyone and everyone was like sis she
was calling everyone her sister this is
my sister it's my family and like she
wasn't even being like thirsty like that
is how it is
she was not nervous for one second she
always had like the next question coming
to her mouth and so many people stopped
by they were like i literally never do
interviews at the top of the carpet but
i had to come see lala like kim and pete
would never have done the vogue
livestream courtney and travis did it
gabrielle union did it so many so many
of the celebrities were like i had to
come say hi to you i never do this like
they just want to go inside it's been
like a long evening so far the anxiety
they just go inside she was incredible i
hope she gets the gig every year she was
the best host i've ever seen like she
she should be on me like she was
incredible amazing incredible i had to
give a shout out wow her outfit you
should just jump right in because we're
already into it and we haven't even let
you know no that without further ado
because there's been a ton of ado here
are the past five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
figs figs is on a mission to make
awesome scrubs suited for the awesome
humans working in healthcare forget boxy
itchy cotton scrubs figs are engineered
to be ridiculously soft and incredibly
durable using their innovative technical
comfort technology figs blends comfort
style and durability into high
performance scrubs that help you perform
at your best whatever the day throws at
you so they're super functional they
focus on design function and comfort
they have a proprietary four-way stretch
fabric for a ridiculously soft feel and
they have to in some of their styles
they have up to 20 pockets um also if
you're not a nurse because i'm obviously
not a nurse but i'm always looking for
stretchy
lovely breathable clothing to wear in my
home since my spooky scary skeletons
unfortunately are starting to rip terry
and figs is kind of everything like
they're first of all the patterns are
really really cute they have tons of
different designs and i just love a
stretchy material to lounge around in
you can also mix and match any of their
core scrubs with with each other for a
quick wardrobe refresh um 100 awesome
core scrubs that include pants and tops
and a rainbow of color options with one
to three pockets for the convenient
access to your everyday carry figs
believes that the awesome humans in
healthcare deserve scrubs that match i
know we have a lot of toaster nurses so
if you're just tired of the itchy itchy
scrubs where figs.com use code toast to
get 15 off your first order so again
that's where figs w-e-a-r-f-i-g-s
dot com code is toast for 15 off your
first order and thank you to all of our
nurses who are consistently doing the
most today's episode is also brought to
you by the pill club access to
reproductive health care has become much
harder and unnecessarily complicated for
women in recent years
you can get time and peace of mind back
with favor their licensed medical team
puts you puts your health first with
access to affordable birth control skin
care menstrual care sexual wellness
products and more all with an online
subscription so you know them formerly
as the pill club they're now rebrand we
love a rebrand to favor and they're
doing everything for you for your
reproductive help the pill club is now
favor they offer professionally
prescribed birth control subscriptions
and sexual wellness products delivered
straight to your door for free they
carry over 120 fda approved brands they
ship to all 50 states and most brands of
birth control are free with insurance or
medicaid otherwise prices start as low
as seven dollars a month without
insurance favor delivers birth control
to your door for free and discreet
packaging along with fun self-care
goodies
their licensed medical team is just a
text away to provide you with the care
that you deserve so you can sign up for
birth control in just five minutes skip
the office and waiting in line at the
pharmacy and get treated right so i know
so many of you are pill club customers
and you love it they have rebranded to
favor and they are doing the most
consistently right now when you go to
heyfavor.com toast they're offering a 10
donation to bedsider.org
for every morning toast listener who
becomes a patient your donation will
help low-income individuals get access
to birth control through bedsider.org
that's hey favor.com toast to get your
first birth control care package and
donate to help more women in need of
affordable birth control that's
hayfavor.com toast and you must use that
link if you want to make sure the
donation goes through
great thank you claudia
that's beautiful
now it's time to launch in to the met
gala 2022 red carpet fashion moments so
everything if you guys want to follow
along with us we are looking at the
vogue we'll post it in our instagram but
it is the vogue article met gala 2022
red carpet fashion they're doing you
know a list of everyone and we're going
to go through all of them there's 210
people on the list we'll be skipping
anyone who is deeply um
not someone that we know yeah
that's a nice way of saying yeah
okay first up could talk about them for
a year
kim and pete pete wearing dior men and
kim kardashian in vintage jean-louis
also known as marilyn monroe's happy
birthday mr president dress from the
1960s from ripley's believe it or not
what's so funny to me is like the
ripley's believe it or not of it all
because ripley's is like such like a
it's like a times square tacky branch
orlando it's like pt barnum yeah like
and you would think a dress like this
would be like sotheby's or something
like really legit but ripley's first of
all is so respectful of kim first of all
they totally
are obsessed with her they gave her a
box of marilyn monroe's hair oh my god
yeah so they're like loving this
partnership they made all these this
cute content on their instagram yeah i
saw the reel so i just wanted to say
like the ripley's element is making me
giggle yeah um but to kim i mean
it's crazy how i literally was just and
everyone waiting and waiting and waiting
we weren't even sure we never got
confirmation if this was the dress she
was wearing it was just speculation but
then before she hit the carpet vogue
released the photos um
in which they say she's wearing the real
dress
it looks zipped
but on the carpet she wore the real
dress as well but she wore a fur stole
around the back because it didn't zip
all the way yeah so i just don't
understand how in the photos on vogue
they said she's wearing the real one and
it looks she she shows the back and it's
zipped maybe it's photoshopped some
movie members or maybe it should yeah
like or they've had something in place
that made it look like it zipped the
whole putting out the picture first was
very confusing i don't think it was a
mistake me there um
it was just confusing i thought she
wasn't gonna walk the carpet if that's
what they if they were like putting out
these the same photos first maybe those
photos were even taken like days ago
yeah that's what i was thinking you know
so that she could ensure that she got
the look because she wasn't sure if it
was going to fit i mean
getting
i love how open she's being about the
journey to getting it to fit she said
that she had this idea to wear it she
tried it on at ripley's three weeks ago
it didn't zip she told them that she was
going to lose the weight and they were
like they didn't believe it and she
ripley's believe it or not she said
ripley believe it or not i'm going gonna
lose 16 pounds in three weeks and she
did and she looks amazing she looks so
skinny so snatch and she but i love that
she's like so open she's like i'm so
hungry i'm so excited to have pizza and
donuts after this but she like she said
it's like getting into a role right so
you know that's how really she sees it
so there's been like a lot of backlash
obviously kim i haven't unrealistic
yadda yadda
where's the backlash but like you know
everywhere i just don't ever remember
seeing that backlash for you know
joaquin phoenix right or jared leto the
way that kim described it as like
getting ready for a role this is the
biggest night of her year this is like
the pinnacle of all things fashion i
didn't find it offensive at all i
thought it was just quite impressive i
don't know how one person loses 16
pounds in three weeks but like somebody
tell me how to do it no that's i need to
go on the kim marilyn i could never
really diet i could never 16 pounds in
three weeks sounds good to me that's
insane insane um pete was there too
looking cute he got a spray tan
did you know that oh no i didn't know
that but he does look like tan he has a
nice glow yeah cause like two days ago
he did this like netflix they honored
joan rivers george carlin it was like it
actually looked really cool um and he
was on stage talking about it we got a
spray tan and i was like you do look
tanner that's really funny so they were
giving us so many moments and now it
kind of makes sense why they did their
first red carpet a few days ago because
like
if they did all of this for the first
time it just would have been too much i
think but now we're almost like used to
them yes and they weren't giving like
looking at each other like they're so
comfortable they're so comfortable they
were just like parading down the carpet
and it's very very cute but just
something about i mean
just something about it just like pulled
out my heartstrings just for kanye no i
know because that was like their event
yeah that was their thing also what i
thought was interesting were the shoes
kim was wearing they were like enormous
clear platform like clod hoppers but
because she couldn't tailor it and she's
so short like people don't even realize
so um at least her shoes are comfortable
because you have to wear like you know
painfully
torturous shoes yeah and then once she
got up the steps she changed into a
replica of the dress that fit better
that was more comfortable and that she
could dance eat and party the night
right she said she was never going to
eat in the dress because she's history
she couldn't wear any body makeup you
know her kkw body foundation not as much
as she normally would oh i thought she
said none i think she said not the body
makeup i normally wear but there's
definitely some
[ __ ] shine also let's talk about the
hair because we were saying we hope she
goes for her signature hair and while i
actually
i'm not mad to be wrong i love the
blonde but i'm glad she didn't do like
costume marilyn monroe bob because they
order a marilyn wig on amazon right
because then that looks like tacky and
like she made it her own and i actually
loved the hair and she's staying blonde
she said yes love that for her
i i would have liked like og original
recipe kim hair but like this is
gorgeous there's nothing
there's nothing to dislike about the
entire experience i loved every minute
of it it was well worth the wait yeah
she is a queen she owns this
this event
it's it's not a surprise that honestly
no other a-listers go because it's
literally turned into the kardashian
gala yeah and i'm just glad that now
they are all there and they can all
enjoy in it i just well i have so many
thoughts on the rest of them so let's
just do kardashians first and then we'll
get into the rest of the people okay up
on my worst dress list is courtney and
travis okay um first of all it was not
in theme and if you're not going to be
in theme you have to look glamorous and
it was not glamorous at all it was quite
ugly um
and i hated every minute of it when she
explained it she did the interview with
lala and i just have to say if courtney
never gets invited back to the met gala
it's for this particular reason she was
so like
you know when you go it's [ __ ]
because it's like
it's you know this really pretentious
affair and you really have to like
bow down and be like this is so amazing
i'm so honored and courtney wasn't
wasn't doing that like part of me loves
her for that but part of me knows like i
honestly think if anna winter saw her
interview she would not get invited back
because lala was like when you heard the
theme
a steamy lexicon america guilded
whatever what came to what did you think
about and she was like giggling like
honestly like i didn't think of anything
and it was just like it could be
perceived as disrespectful even though
like i get it like this is so high brow
it's like stupid i totally get it but i
do think like she didn't have any
reverence toward the thing yeah well you
know what i kind of have respect for
that because like this event has snubbed
her like year after year so like to come
in and not be like groveling thirsty i
have a lot of respect for but i think
that what the question that lasts is a
really good one and this is like the
first time in a long time where the
theme is extremely tangible and like you
could point to something
that
it sparks in you this theme it's not
like it's commas to garcin's and we
don't know what we're celebrating right
you know i hated her outfit so much so
she said that her outfit was the
deconstructed version of travis's
they're both wearing tom brown and i
believe in my heart that she had no say
in what she's wearing it has nothing to
do with courtney i'm sure she was just
happy to be invited it is ugly
yeah no it's not for me
but they were obviously meant to be worn
together and travis's as an outfit alone
i do like i think it's a a nice handsome
man outfit i like when the men are
wearing like are in theme a little bit
you know
fun with it but looking classy and and
white tie that's the other thing it's
like this event was white tie which is
even more fancy than black tie and i
felt like a lot of the outfits didn't
adhere to that
like attire yeah that's true like anyone
who's wearing a
short dress mini dress oh not not are
you okay
um yeah i think yeah i'm good i don't
know what happened okay cool um all
right next kardashian who's up on my
best dressless
is shockingly chris [ __ ] jenner
yes this second she walked out of the
mark i knew the reference i knew the
moment i loved the hair the dress was
beyond flattering the one glove she
literally looked the best she's ever
looked in her entire life and corey
wearing blue
with that yellow it was giving like
belle and the prince yeah but she was
mostly giving jackie o which on its own
gorgeous love it she really nailed it
and i do think that that's a reference
that you know you it's hard to measure
up too
and then on top of that you have like
jackie oh and marilyn yeah and it's just
really cute like her and kim i don't
know if they planned it or that was just
like a cute aside that they realized
that they could do plus it's just like
if the theme is american icons like they
are the two yeah uh i thought it was
adorable i loved it like i just didn't
see
me thinking chris jenner because you
know chris is really interesting she's
always at the met gala with whichever of
her daughters are going but she's very
much like in the background her outfits
just kind of like
are acceptable they're like on par
they're not like going to change lives
so you don't really expect a lot fashion
wise from chris you know she's really
there to support her daughters but she
stole the [ __ ] show she
literally did i would have loved to see
that look on any of the girls kylie
kendall
agreed yeah but chris was just
perfection like i cannot stress enough
how weirdly she might be my best dressed
yeah no she's she's on my list we will
share our best and more stress after
this but i also need to go through
everything to make sure that my list
runs the gamut so i loved chris let's go
to kendall kendall i liked she's always
number one best dress for me she's not
this year but she looked very nice very
nice i loved the bleach brows
yeah that i felt seen yeah no eyebrow
moment i don't really have a lot to say
i thought it was in theme and it was
pretty but it wasn't going to change
anyone's lives yeah agreed then let's
talk about probably the most divisive
outfit divisive divisive yeah outfit on
the red carpet people were shook people
thought it was a joke and it was kylie's
off-white wedding dress ball cap
veil moment
i
like love it i know you do when i first
saw it i was
not obsessed but not only did it grow on
me and like she really is the american
bride that's i think the
the reference there like
the ball cap there's nothing more
american than that she had been working
with virgil since 2020 to go to the met
gala so it was all an homage to virgil
but i also just loved like how she
looked in it i thought she looked so
confident and even like no she's been
sharing a lot of like her personal
journey i thought she just looked
amazing she looks like she was having
fun and she was feeling herself and
she wore the look you know the look did
not wear her and overall the more i saw
on her it on her i was just like she
looks adorable
okay it
it grew on me
but it was ugly i'm sorry and i think
it's awesome that she honored virgil and
that she's sharing all these text
messages and it's really beautiful but
even on the off-white instagram like
they weren't really explaining how it
was in theme so i didn't really feel
like it was in theme and then i didn't
feel like it was particularly beautiful
therefore it's a no for me it's not on
my worst dress list because i agree she
wore the dress she looked like she was
having fun and she looked cute like in a
costumey kind of way yeah but it is not
the vibe sorry i just really liked it on
her if anybody else was wearing it i
feel like i wouldn't have liked it as
much
but
she just looked really happy i know i
think you're blind
i'm blinded by like this kylie
simpatico
erotico connection i'm feeling right now
but she also just like looked really
happy looked like herself she just
looked like a kid having fun she looked
like a kid having fun but it was not
um
what it needed to be but also like
knowing it's virgil knowing it's
off-white and that is like the off-white
thing like taking things and then just
like taking things that are classic and
putting like the white spin on it i just
i really
enjoyed it so much more than i thought
that i would when i first saw it it was
going to be and every picture i'm seeing
for her she's just
being a cutie and then also the picture
at the top of the steps kendall and
kylie together made both of their looks
make more sense i completely agree and
for a moment i thought maybe kendall was
also wearing off-white because when they
were just like you know big brown big
black ball gown big white ball gown like
it was
they were like meant they were like yin
and yang but they weren't meant to be
simpatico outfits no but it was a really
cute moment and it made me like kylie's
outfit more i agree yeah and then we had
chloe who was wearing moschino who i
thought looked great yeah she was
guilded it was just there was nothing
like um avant-garde or you know we knew
about it yeah but she looked gorgeous
safe
safe in theme you know what she
literally should have worn remember when
they had the gatsby themed party and she
wore that headpiece with the matching
dress
that was the vibe i feel like she was
very nervous she was so excited to be
there and i think she just wanted to
like get out unscathed it was a very
safe choice i wasn't like sold on the
ruffle but it was cute and it was pretty
and it was fine yeah and i'm sure like
she felt really good in it
and
had a really good night partying the
night away yeah and she's like fun and i
think she just wanted to get the carpet
over with she has bad anxiety she didn't
want people to like she didn't want to
do anything sort of like confusing or
you know you need a degree in fashion to
understand like she just wants to look
pretty and she looks pretty and she
looks pretty however all together no
family looked like a mess clowns
i'm gonna be honest with you you look
like [ __ ] clowns
but like everyone at the mac gala it's a
clowny affair yes i was just watching
this video like celebrities they all
went with the same designer like they
were going to look not cohesive you know
i was actually thinking how iconic it
would be if they were all with the same
designer
um i don't know who that be would be
like for a while i felt like it was like
them and bomb on like besties but i
don't look like kim wears mom on anymore
she's like moved on to like blanciaga i
think she's like still has love in her
heart for olivier but but i don't think
it's like her vibe she's graduated so i
don't know if there ever could be a
world in which they all because they all
have like their different aesthetics and
their different
brand associations
so i was thinking that it would be cool
if they all did like a cohesive look
especially for the first year that they
were there but kim needed this moment it
was iconic no complaints maybe next year
i would absolutely love that and any
designer should like just have a
kardashian table a grade
okay now we're going to scroll down to
nicki minaj who is wearing a very kylie
look but she's in burberry she's also in
the ball cap and and she's also on my
worst dresser a big gown i'm not loving
it let me tell you why first of all
in the words of nicki minaj i hate
hate your hair and makeup today no her
hair makeup looks fine i hate the hat
more than anything the dress did not fit
on the live stream with lala she was
covering her boobs like it was not
properly altered to fit her breasts
which is just not okay
um i hated everything about this i
thought the body jewels were really cool
she said they were done by pat mcgrath
that was really cool um her glam is
great hate literally everything else
about this love the glam love the jewels
i actually have an appreciation for the
hat just because it's so american and
okay and it would be remiss devastating
and heartbroken if no one wore a ball
kappa i tried to incorporate it into
their look okay hey yeah it's hard to
make a ball cap white tie but they tried
their best hey
next we have lily james looking you know
really beautiful and really basic and
looking like she's going to chris
jenner's um great gatsby themed party
yeah no i love i love the dress there's
nothing not to like it's not doing
anything like abs new but like she looks
gorgeous
um i don't love the hair i was just
gonna say that maybe it's because i
loved her so much as like a platinum
blonde in pam and tommy i thought it was
like the color she should have forever i
actually really don't like this hair i
think it ages her yeah i would agree
next we have normani and christian
siriano i think she's a lot of people's
one of their best agreed she looks
amazing love the hat her body's on fleek
black they were explaining on one of the
live streams like a lot of people are
wearing black and for a reason it's in
theme so i don't really know why but
black is in theme um and i love it love
love it's not like
life-changing but it's really good you
know what i like about it it's like if
you had covered the midriff like it
really could have been worn right back
so it's a modern take and it's a very
much like a pop stars tape agreed on a
gilded era dress agreed the hat is
extremely
miss marianne yeah from the gilded age
and
all in all i'm here for it that's
actually a really good point if you were
to cover the midriff it like could have
been worn back in the day yeah it's very
good it's very very good and the makeup
is sickening yes
the green eyeshadow is the choice oh i
like it yeah no it makes it more fun
right next we have gabrielle union in
versace
amazing really and on the live stream
she looked incredible talking to lala
there was like
so much meaning behind it
it is i loved did she explain the bo the
flower
um no but she was wearing these like a
red a string of red
not like pearls but like rubies in her
hair
because you know it's like the gilded
age and as a black woman like how do you
celebrate that so it was like the blood
sweat and tears it was really meaningful
and i think maybe the
the bow has something to do with that
yeah the flower i loved it loved and
dwayne wade looks great too so i love
this i'm not loving the flower like it's
giving period
okay but it's giving period peace
[Laughter]
maybe that's the message i love it but i
love the train i love
i love the combination of sparkles and
the feathers and everything i agree love
then there's wayne wayne then there's
wayne rooney matching
sexy gorgeous kane i love the cane
we should have seen more canes agreed
carl delevingne was i think the only
other person who had a cane
uh next we have sierra and michael kors
and behind her courtney and travis doing
their tongues on the met gala and i just
want to say like i'm glad that they did
that because that's what everybody
wanted to see this is um
it's okay
she looks beautiful she could do no
wrong but this could be worn to any
event the grammys yeah anything she
looks stunning not super gilded but like
but fine i would rather be a little not
in theme but looking beautiful
than the theme to a t and being a clown
billy eilish
that's exactly who did that but we'll
get there
next we have sydney sweeney and tori
burch and considering she's the girl of
the moment she's like couldn't be more
it
it's a little disappointing i completely
agree the train did come off into a mini
dress so she was giving you know chuggy
millennial at her wedding in the after
party dress um it did remind me a lot of
kim on the cover of vogue like the
really dark eye makeup yeah and then
like the strapless it was pretty i saw a
lot of people wearing wedding dresses
and i don't know if that means it's a
part of the theme is that something
that's about the the american anthology
i have no idea but this is very pretty
but very boring yeah i don't think we
invented the white wedding dress
actually i believe it was queen victoria
who first wore white to her wedding
so if you're if it's an homage to queen
victoria then i'm here for it
it was fine it was fine i expected more
from her just because like she
is no one more current yeah and i i
don't know i think she might have like
some sort of partnership with tory burch
but i thought the decision to go with
tory burch is kind of random yeah
because tory burch is very classy very
elegant but it's not show-stopping
you know life-changing industry changing
yeah
next we have lizzo and her flute in tom
brown sickening yeah the fact that tom
brown made this outfit and kourtney
kardashian's means courtney didn't get
enough time in her meeting um i you know
she's holding one of the most expensive
expensive flutes in the world as a 55
000 flute oh my god the jacket was so
sick from the back and when she took it
off inside the dress was like this
deconstructed corset sickening from
every
she nailed it from
visuals and also theme
the jacket is so one theme and a
deconstructed corset is so in theme and
a flute is always in theme sickening
loved this sh and she also was making
content in the bathroom at the mac ella
we are grateful she was very like
searching for kim she just wanted to
meet kim like we are obsessed and she
killed it well she should have been at
courtney's table with tom brown so right
even though i know they sit by designer
but i saw a picture maybe they all just
like got up and changed because all the
kardashians were sitting at the same
table yeah you'd love to see it yeah
next katy perry and oscar de la renta
jail go to jail this is a crime every
other picture that i saw i would agree
in this picture though
i like it more than i've liked it before
i hate but it's just a lot going on it's
giving
funeral it's giving mess
and this doesn't even look like oscar de
la renta
yeah it's bad
it's not great no no but you know what
it's nice to see her doing something
different as opposed to being like a
giant hamburger agreed and that's what
she said she's like this is the most
comfortable like she was um interviewed
by vanessa and she said like i'm always
like doing the most so it's nice to just
be here in a dress oh that's really
funny and i feel that
next miranda kerr and oscar de la renta
another wedding dress
is this her wedding dress if i were
invited to the met gala though like as a
lay person but without like you know a
designer on tap so many people like go
and they have to dress themselves yeah
wear your wedding dress you guys you
really can't go wrong you could dye it
you know you're never gonna wear it
again that's true my wedding dress would
be good for any mascara
and i have two of them so i can go for
two years you guys okay good good to
know just in case anyone wants to invite
me um but this looks like it would be
her wedding dress so there's nothing not
to like but it's not you know changing
lives changing lives jasmine tookes and
zuhair murad could be changing lives
though yeah this gorgeous girl this is
pretty sickening yep love the gloves the
hair is so gilded age yeah the dress
love the color
it's not thinking about the shoes it's
really hard for these supermodels to
mess up yes that's true because they
have such like deep
relationships with like the premium
designers and they're literally models
they're like mannequins you know
everything is just works gorgeous the
necklace everything this is beautiful
beautiful
next we have sizza and vivian westwood
i like the hat you do yeah i think it's
like funny and like dramatic and it's
like it's a costume ball so like it's
it's camp
um i like the beat that's what i was
gonna say
um i do not like anything else about
this um
i really don't like like neon pink and
black it's reminds me of hot topic i
agree
um
but the necklace is pretty yeah agreed i
would agree okay
next we have carly kloss in javinci
right in the eye she actually looks
quite dramatic
for her yeah she looks like black swan i
i love it i like it too i don't know if
it's on theme
well you said black is on theme gloves
are on theme yeah i guess
you know this is very boudoir
this is fine again she's a supermodel so
it's really hard for her to look bad in
like what is basically lingerie
um it's so fine
it's so fine not changing lives
next we're going to scroll down a little
bit to one of the men odell beckham jr i
don't know who he's wearing but i really
like it i like it too yeah i don't
unnecessarily understand how it's in
theme agreed but it's really cute and i
love the necklaces he reminds me of us
with our new chains totally
totally okay next we have rosalia and
javon shay
i love this i don't know if it's just
this picture that's amazing i didn't see
the front because the last picture i saw
the front i like wasn't crazy about but
this from the back it's everything yeah
i can't really decide how i feel about
this wait i'm like it's moving up it's
not my best it's not like my top three
but it's encroaching on top the back is
definitely the moment because from the
front i remember being like extremely
underwhelmed i don't really have a
thought on this honestly like i can't
figure out if it's like so ugly or like
really beautiful you know what i need to
seek out one more picture in order to
make and i think it might just be a
really favorable picture yeah and to
show like only one picture on vogue.com
like that's really unfair i know but we
would be here all day no totally okay
i need
here's a okay from the front i don't
love it as much right this is obviously
like a very flattering picture yeah but
you know photos pictures worth a
thousand words okay next up is olivia
rodrigo and i have like so many thoughts
okay what are your thoughts my thoughts
are like now that she's been famous for
like a good amount of time she's done a
lot of red carpets she's been to the
grammys this is her second matt gala
i've come to the conclusion like her red
carpet style like sucks it's not
giving what it's supposed to give like
she is this young pop star and she's
just always looking like
not a young pop star and like this dress
is so fine the gloves are fine i
actually like the hair but it's just
like it's fine
i like it
i just but she's another one where it's
like i would put her with a sydney
sweeney whereas like everybody should be
clamoring to dress her like
uh so it's a little underwhelming but
she is on theme
and i really like it i don't really like
it i i i kind of hate it it's giving
like
cachet prom
okay
okay i i don't feel as harshly towards
it but i respect that you do okay i
think you just have like really big
aspirations for her she as i should
she's a new artist of the year like
she's the it girl of music yes and could
she be prettier yeah
no
next we have russell westbrook love
don't know who he's wearing but i love
it it's so like what a man would have
worn back in the day this is a really
great theme for the men because
all they really have to do is show up in
white tie maybe put like a little flare
some of them had a manicure something
like that
and you nailed it and i think russell
westbrook nailed it agree i love this i
love the hat i love everything and i
love the necklaces making it more
modern agreed love
next sarah senpaio michael kors it's so
michael horse yes it is and it could be
worn anywhere at any time it actually
i'm sorry it sucks because yeah i
it's like two on the nose
you know what it's so boring yeah for a
supermodel yeah
okay we got kendall up kendall who we
discuss cardi b and versace up on my
best dress list yeah i think the coolest
part that i didn't even realize is like
you think those things on her arms are
like cuffs they're stacked bracelets
like it's so sick oh wow um the necklace
the thing on her neck is not a collar
it's stacked necklaces
my only like little caveat to
otherwise what would have been maybe one
of my best dress it looks so similar to
kendall's bomb uh was that bomb on last
year i thought it was javon shane
javanchi the like chandelier moment that
saved the it's literally that in gold
yeah but it is a different designer and
it's clearly made out of like completely
different materials no like all the
enamel versace like if you get up really
close because she was on the live stream
yeah the little versus it's it's so sick
it's up there and i love her hair too
yep and it's gilded and it's oh beyond
guilty it's very on theme this is a
perfect look honestly because it's
gorgeous glamorous sickening agree and
perfectly on theme the hair and makeup
is sickening as well i would agree great
next kylie who we discussed another
photo of her i'm just loving
loving loving oh my god i didn't even
see molly sims so random i kind of love
what she's wearing
you do yeah i mean she looks i like the
dress period but like as a love for a
met gala yeah i actually i do love the
dress and i love the gloves and it's
super fancy it's white tie the sleeves
are giving like roman gilded queen and
the train and everything the cape and
you know what i agree you just put me
around and i love the color yeah no she
looks amazing yeah jack carlo was there
he's really the it boy and he looks
terrible
he's wearing javon she it's giving
nothing i would have loved to seen him
in you know just old school white tie a
grade the coat and everything hate yep
moving on scrolling down to carrie
washington and tory burch very pretty
very pretty she looks great yeah she
looks really great yeah
brooklyn beckham and nicola peltz not in
theme and not that cute both wearing
valentino they look stunning um but not
in theme i agree but she looks great
they could they can do no wrong yeah but
they don't go hard they like looking
nice and beautiful yeah i guess they
don't want to look like clowns i guess i
see that for them though you were going
to catch victoria beckham out here no
but you would catch victoria beckham and
theme but not clowning at least like a
small reference no you can you can be in
theme and not clowney lily james
yeah khloe kardashian yep agreed
this is giving like real housewives trip
to morocco like that's what you would
wear on a sand dune yeah
okay fair so you a little disappointing
though yeah
cara delevingne in dior
i haven't had a chance to really study
this one she's body painted wearing
nipple covers and a lot of jewels
um
i just can't like and she has the cane i
don't really um
i skilled it
it is kills it okay like i don't really
hate it
i don't know
it's a little too nude for my liking but
with the coat on like her i think it
would have been very cool with the coat
on it
she would have been having like a
masculine take on the theme with like
you know some body paint it's just a lot
i don't know
it's not my favorite
uh it's not my favorite but it's not my
least favorite at all
i have to remember to do my least
favorite yeah um next we have kiki lane
in probable garang and i just [ __ ]
love
it's
perfection it's perfection the gloves
the detail it's
everything of the sort just need to make
a note on my best
yeah that's definitely up there for best
i love it i love it so much i could look
at it all day it's really something it's
really really the hair the gloves the
very simple accessories it's perfection
yeah okay now scrolling down to kid cudi
in kenzo oh it's nice i love this i like
this too because it's it's gilded but
it's fun i love the color
i love it it's very cute and it's
handsome it's handsome i completely
agree wow chloe looks amazing that's a
great picture i'm so happy that she like
got to wear something that like you know
she's feeling like the snatcher in yeah
and like she would wear that
to a red carpet and i love the gloves
yeah i love it i haven't had i hadn't
seen this picture she looks incredible
so many gloves and i loved the gloves
like the opera gloves i loved the gloves
for everyone okay next we have gwen
stefani and vera wang okay it's worth
noting she did her own makeup because
like last minute her makeup artist
bounced and like good luck trying to
find a makeup artist met gala monday um
and i thought her makeup looked really
good so i just wanted to say that this
is a very bad picture of it um
i don't hate it
i just don't understand it given like
the theme yeah you didn't see a lot of
neon
right right no i agree but she looks
pretty she does look pretty and she's
gwen stefani so if anyone's gonna shake
it up it's gonna be her i agree she's
shaking it up chicago and she looks like
she's having fun you know what i would
have done in my makeup artist canceled i
would have called like emma
chamberlain's because you know he was
done early right she got there late too
yeah so you could have someone do your
whole glam in the time that the red
carpet is going on even though i think
that yeah actually no you're 100 right
yeah 100
uh okay next joshua jackson and jody
turner smith she looks incredible
gorgeous gorgeous and they were being
like so annoyingly cute with lala like
they're obsessed they were literally
like being like courtney and travis like
obsessed with each other um he looks
nice as a couple they're looking great
as a couple as a couple him on his own
like i'm not crazy about the pants no no
but she is
um a goddess this is like maybe one of
the best women outfits agreed totally
agree okay next is someone who i'm also
loving lucy boynton just looking like
sweet as sugar yeah i totally forgot
about her like yeah as a person
she always looks
great and always on theme never doing
the most yeah never doing the least yes
agreed it's perfectly mid i love it
she's just a fashion girly she never
misses agreed okay now we have dove
cameron um i'm happy that she was there
because you know i'm a dove girly but
i'm not loving this look it looks like
it came off the descendants set it's
messy
but i also think she's someone who
didn't have a say agreed she was just so
thrilled to be invited and i'm thrilled
for her me too and her face looks pretty
her hair looks great yeah next we have
the snatcher addison ray
um
you know like very nice like very
grammys
yeah she looks better than she did last
year so she's moving on up which is
always good yeah um she looks like she
was having a lot of fun in the dress
yeah she it's a very flattering cut i
love a halter
it's not
you know going to shake up the fashion
industry by any means
but it's like it's like safe you know i
feel like with a lot of these looks it's
like you don't necessarily some people
want to be avant-garde and like want to
do like cara delevingne like wants to do
the most doesn't want to be safe ever
but some people just like want not to
end up on the worst dress list agreed
and this is totally that 100
i did think it was a little ill-fitting
around the breast like in some of the
photos it's just like
material bunching up but i think she
looks very very pretty and she looks
like herself which is nice yeah and i'm
sure she like had a great night and
they'll be comfortable with the night
away with her friends and totally i'm
happy for her i love seeing her at these
events agreed
next we have taylor hill
a best dressed
for sure a great but again for the
supermodels it's just not fair to put
them on the best dress list honestly
yeah but it's like why couldn't any
celebrity wear what they're wearing no
this dress is really spectacular it's
spectacular it's gilded age it's fashion
it's matt gala it's white thai agreed
it's gorgeous gorgeous girly gor it's a
gorgeous gorgeous girly moment for sure
oh my god we are only at number 47 out
of 200 i know we're 10 and i think the
episode's already over no but you know
what like
i feel like after 100 like we don't know
any of those people okay okay
next we have aquafina jail
[Laughter]
next we have emily ratajkowski also jeff
also cellmate with aquafina
they could cherish hell this is one of
actually i hadn't had a wurst yet but i
need yeah emily's up there i need to uh
it's really bad yep it's really and i
know that it's like very special it's
like atelier uh versace hasn't been worn
since yasmeen i get it it's ugly agreed
next we have lily aldridge in kite and
i'm loving it i didn't even see it up
until now and she's
unbelievably gorgeous another one the
supermodel that yes
it looks agreed yeah i love it
next we have simone ashley in moschino
this was like her
night because she is like the bridgeton
girly i didn't see her till now i was
wondering if she was there i have to say
the bridgeton girlies as a whole didn't
really do it for me in in the way that
they should have given that they wear
these dresses on set
this is fine but it's not like she she
could have done more same with phoebe
denver yeah she was like actually bad
yeah also imagine being phoebe and like
your ex is with kim shutting down the
carpet oh my god right there were so
many like weird moments kaya gerber and
jacob lordy and austin butler vanessa
hudgins austin butler yes that's a real
one because they dated for 10 10 years
phoebe deniver and p dated for 10
minutes three weeks yeah yeah so i'm
sure it hurts less but still like
they're the talk of the ton the ton and
you're showing up like
absolutely
is like very meh
yes but good yeah good she's good she's
safe agreed she's been mark's safe yeah
literally
next chloe bailey
horrible i don't like the color i think
in a different color i would have really
liked the color is so tacky i like the
neck thing me too but i hate the dress
yeah agreed um oh and naomi campbell i
didn't even know the camel in burberry
loving she always looks agreed wonderful
agreed
next you have um dakota johnson jared
leto and alessandro michelle all in
gucci with the gucci designer
together they look great yeah i like
dakotas it's not like amazing it's very
much taylor swift 1989 tour yes but it's
cute it's cute and it's a dakota
sandwich in this picture and i love
dakota she's really like an it girl for
me and i love jared leto i didn't
realize that he was there because
everybody thought he was the other guy
yeah totally i thought that too okay
next kate moss boring i like it because
it's like a deconstructed tuxedo
boring
i think that she looks good
uh next we have future
also in like a take on the tuxedo white
tie cute cute yeah
next oh maisie williams yeah i didn't
recognize her williams because she went
without eyebrows but her outfit is great
yeah it is
it's wonderful yeah huh next we have
christine brazanski who is
baranski who is the gilded age oh right
she's adelaide or whatever aunt aydah
aydah aydah um she looks great actually
this is obviously like a masculine take
on white tie and i think it's really
pretty actually yeah but i
like a couple of the girlies from gilded
h1 including meryl streep's daughter and
including peggy
and why didn't they just borrow outfits
from the set like it's
a grade that would have been so iconic
agreed like we literally have a show
called the gilded age right now and
that's the theme even though meryl
streep's daughter whose name i cannot
remember
jacob looked great she did but she is
the gilded age queenie yeah and she
didn't look so gilded yeah next eva chen
and peter dough and i really like this
me too and the photo vogue is using is
extremely unflattering because on the
other side it's off the shoulder and
it's it's gilded it's it's great i love
this yeah it's a combo of the men's and
the women's exactly
um okay we need to move it along hayley
bieber and saint laurent stuff
shut it down she's a safe queen but she
always like looks so gorgeous
with a tip with a hint of the theme
agreed and looking like herself and like
she's gonna dance comfortably gonna
dance the night away agreed i love this
agreed love it's very safe she's a safe
queen yes next we have arena shake in
burberry horrible yeah no it's really
really bad horrible
yeah next jessica chastain and gucci not
my favorite not my favorite but she
looks really nice and beautiful jacob
lordy giving us nothing but why but he's
giving us like a man's look with a
little bit of sequins it's nothing i
like it he looks so handsome sometimes
when like sometimes for the men all you
got to do is look sharp
but i know you disagree with me because
like for my for my best dressed men it's
shawn mendes me too and austin butler
who didn't even wear classic tuxedos so
you could do so much more i'm sorry this
is so boring and it's first of all it's
white tie and you're wearing a uh a tie
which is like cocktail attire okay fine
so it's horrible horrible it's horrible
i think it's safe anita best dress
literally the pearls the silhouette it's
everything
gorgeous gorgeous girly i love
david lauren ralph lauren's son jail
okay but in his
in his defense he is literally a
combination of american anthology and
guilded asians he's got
genes on the bottom
and a tuxedo on top i actually
appreciate the thought madeleine petch
stunning
stunning i love it it's a perfect girls
like really show up camila mendes and
they always like they're never the best
like most memorable but they're never
the worst no and they always get it on
theme and they always look beautiful
yeah and they're always like respecting
the
institution agreed and i think madison
institute madeleine looks amazing yes
next your favorite fashion icon maggie
rogers she looks horrible and
literally her red carpet
style is probably my least favorite in
all of hollywood
wow that's a big statement this is
really bad you know who my least
favorite red carpet style and all of
hollywood is who ben platt yes i did
know that jackie has like a hard-on for
ben platt his met gala looks two years
in a row are my worst wow
lenny kravitz cute
yeah cute very lenny phineas actually
looks great phineas o'connell that's his
last name i guess um no i thought it was
ferb i thought it was eilish
oh right no but her name is like
beatrice she has like a crazy long name
um he looks good actually very on theme
yeah
oh wow that was real like i didn't
expect you to say that like i get it i
don't think it's stunning but i get it
okay ariana dubose in moschino
perfection
yeah perfection
yeah i need to see it more close up
sabrina carpenter and paco rabon giving
safe queen giving us nothing but a
little bit of something but i expect
safe queen from sabrina carpenter she's
just happy to be there totally okay one
of my biggest disappointments of the
night is meghan the stallion in moschino
it's so costumey but that's the mosquito
way yeah i know but it's like it's
almost so costly that it's not beautiful
i understand i'm not living for this but
that's how i feel about ariana debose a
little bit too and she also went with
moschino i think it might be the
coloring then or like the feather
shoulders she's looking like an extra in
game of thrones yeah
but that's just the moschino take on
things yeah but i'm not here for it um
rege jean paige
giving us nothing considering my bar for
the men is so low i actually do not like
this i don't like it especially like you
were in bridgerton do better
borrow something from the set 100
oh my god so random was sigourney weaver
and i just want to say i think she might
be my best dressed i just love her so
much like thank you michael kors for
paying homage to like one of the
greatest actresses of our time who
doesn't get any recognition i [ __ ]
love sigourney weaver and i think she
looks sickening okay where's the lie
where's the lie yup oh mayor adams um
wearing a jacket telling to end gun
violence when he's the one who could do
that but he's at the mat gala right so
um cute so it's a no so cute
uh
oh
oh i thought that was someone else sorry
oh um winnie harlow in iris van harpen
looking really cute
i don't really understand how it would
be on theme it's giving more heavenly
bodies
it is but it's really pretty i love it
so much he's another one like
supermodels get the best looks so easy
but i i hadn't seen it um from the front
i hadn't seen her red carpet pictures i
just saw like pictures of her with other
people i absolutely love and adore a
door and i might have to add it to my
list yeah
now this next person i really want your
take on okay it's penelope featherington
oh i saw her what do you think about it
so it's like not my favorite look and as
we've discussed pink and black are not
my favorite combination but i'm really
happy for her even though she became
extremely radical and
off the rails in
bridgerton and so she's really hard to
sympathize with like i'm happy that
she's there i hope that she met kim
commissioner that they talk and kim's
obsessed and obviously kim's not going
to fan go over phoebe okay i have to say
this might be like an extremely hot take
but i absolutely love this
first of all the pink and the black is
not bothering me i didn't even realize
it was pink and black until you just
said that and pink and black usually
does bother me i love the feathers
especially since she's the penelope
featherington the silhouette is so
brighter to in the sleeves and i just
know how hard it is as a chubby girl to
look good on a red carpet because
designers like are not used to
dressing chubby people and i think she
looks unbelievably gorgeous like i'm
obsessed you know what the more i'm
looking at it the more i'm loving it she
and she's wearing it it's not wearing
you're doing great things keep talking
i'm gonna be up my best dress i don't
know if she's blonde but the blonde is
gorgeous she is when you look at her
instagram she is not penelope she is
nicola i think this is so special
honestly like i know it could be like a
little clownish because it's like
feathers and there's like it's the
costume ball i actually love it i really
it's not my best dress but i think it
deserves a moment
you know what it's really grown on me i
love the jewels i i do i love the pliny
pink
okay good i'm glad like i just wanted to
make an impact look at you okay next are
my best dress
couple of the night shut it down
everyone else go home we have elon and
mae musk wearing dior and i'm obsessed i
have to say elon's outfit is finally one
person wore just men's white tie he has
the tails on he has a white tie on it's
white tie and that's literally what the
[ __ ] attire was and nobody wore white
tie so kudos to elon for just reading
the invitation right and mei actually
looks like she could be going to a gala
at the vanderbilt like that is what they
wore yeah i think that they look so
amazing i love that he brought may like
the month but with an e yes elon thank
you for spelling my name it's the first
may it's the first monday in may oh my
god you don't understand how obsessed i
am like i wish there was an account that
was just like the elon tracker at the
met i need to know everyone that he
spoke to who we danced with if like he's
a single man right now right who was he
flirting with we need to be looking at
this carpet with a keener eye who would
spark elon joy interest sabrina
carpenter
sorry she was just behind him and he was
also seen mingling with chris of course
of course jim and pete and i'm sorry
those are the only people at the whole
gala that i'm interested in if you threw
in frank catania i would have a heart
attack you know what the fact that frank
catania wasn't invited is so disgusting
it's disgusting anna has no taste all
right next up is your favorite human
being on planet earth it's ben platt now
tell me why you hate this look so much
because honestly i don't mind it do i
think it's amazing no it's very mid
honestly i don't know why i hate it so
much because i do think if someone else
was wearing it i might feel differently
i think you maybe hate ben platt i think
maybe he do too but i know that i don't
like no you know what i've started to
like like him a lot less only because
i've heard he's like so nasty you know
he has a policy where he doesn't take
pictures with fans excuse me
that's so rude
yeah
i just like really don't like this on
him but i actually like the outfit on
someone else on someone else i feel that
for you i can't explain it i feel like i
might have said the same exact thing
last year when he went like full 70s
denim for american lexicon which kind of
was like on theme right right outfit was
like fine
it's not the designer's fault yeah you
know um next up is billy eilish and i
feel like this dress
is so on theme the the styling is so on
theme and it is so
so ugly
but i like the dress
like off of her yeah no i'm the way my
phone just cut her head off
um if you guys like okay so without okay
if you look at it headless what do you
think it's just like it belongs in the
costume instead
no it looks like it's a set uh um a
costume on the gilded age set it's gucci
by the way and now looking at it
headless i love it it's quite beautiful
but it doesn't work on billy i don't
know why i couldn't tell you why maybe
her hair was blonde again but it's just
not working sometimes things just don't
work you guys agreed
i agree it's not working
next oh i just want to talk about shalom
harlow and ralph lauren because i
absolutely adore yeah i don't know who
she is me neither but i thought her
dress was pretty gorgeous agreed i think
we might have reached the bottom is
there anyone we didn't talk about like
phoebe yeah we didn't talk about kaya
gerber who is another best dress yes
she's on my list for best dressed her
hair was
sickening the
met gala down i loved it the dress was
perfect and her and austin butler are
two of the most gorgeous people on the
planet and it's actually like not fair
that they get to be together yeah but
that they should be together you know
right i also just want to say alexa
chung i don't know who she's wearing but
she's wearing like a simple wedding
dress and i think she looks gorgeous
yeah it's fine i love it it's pretty
bradley cooper was there just like
nothing he just wanted a night out and
wanted to meet some pretty girls it's
giving nothing i hope he met someone i
think that really he was like there just
to schmooze chloe feynman um
looked pretty like i think her outfit
was totally on theme but i'm not crazy
about the turtleneck
yeah i think it's just too much on her
the whole thing agreed
um i feel like we hit everyone i do
alicia keys um at first i really liked
it but the more i looked at it the new
york city landscape on her cape was like
giving tacky times square
yeah sometimes it's too literal i know
you know who we didn't talk about who
was extremely literal on theme gorgeous
stunning and host blake lively oh my god
where is she she was in here so here's
my thoughts on blake lively first of all
the meaning behind her dress was
perfection it was copper and then it was
green to be the statue of liberty um and
on the the train that eventually rolled
out she had all the constellations which
are on the ceiling of grand central
um
it was very on theme very meaningful and
very beautiful but am i crazy or has she
worn that dress before like it looks
like every dress she's always like
wearing the same thing you're thinking
she always looks the same yeah it wasn't
different but it was still really
beautiful but that's why she's not even
close to being on my best dress list
because she was so
the same as always yeah she was gorgeous
she was fashion she was
on theme but she was safe
yeah it's just like it's the same thing
from her i agree the only other person i
want to talk about is hugh jackman
because um
he also
borrowed elon musk's uh
and i think he looks wonderful yeah his
wife on the other hand um she's not a
public figure so i'm actually not going
to drag her but deborah lee fernandez no
but she's having a good time look at
that smile she's like she might be
having a good time but she's not having
a good hair day i'm here and i'm happy
and i'm in tom ford happy for what could
be better also we didn't talk about joe
jonas and sophie turner which are louis
vuitton oh and louis vuitton also did
emma chamberlain emma chamberlain is
really high up she's not my best dress
but i thought she looked she always
looks amazing but even louis vuitton
makes mistakes and joe and sophie were
no and they were and it was joe and
sophie no oh and then my favorite couple
we need to do favorite couples okay my
second favorite couple after elon and
may um georgina chapman and adrian
brodie never get sick of seeing these
two i always forget that they're dating
like consistently forget and he's
another one who just went with
gentleman's white tie yet i'm perfect
fellas
just
be it's so easy it's so easy it's so
easy you don't have to reinvent the
wheel but like see seeing everyone
wearing white tie doesn't make you think
jacob lordy looks stupid
yes and underdressed yes you've
convinced you're doing a lot of
convincing i've had so much time to
think about the met gala and i can't
believe our episode's already over an
hour i have never had to pee more like i
know i'm drinking a whole bottle of
water no i don't know let's we'll
breathe through the rest of the stories
just let you know what's going on um we
need to do our best in our worst okay so
my let's start with best i have so many
just say all of them okay obviously kim
yes
chris i actually think i like better
than kim
whoa
i think like maybe because i was just
surprised by it
cardi b
and kyle gerber
okay
my best rachel hill
taylor hill
why don't you know why i call her rachel
hill i don't know because she looks like
rachel connell
they're [ __ ] yeah they do but her
name is taylor taylor you nailed it
great job kim and chris for sure as a
package duo kiki lane and winnie harlow
are my best for the women for the men it
is elon musk
shawn mendes and hugh jackman for my
best men it is austin butler shawn
mendes oh and also in the women best
kaya gerber yeah forgot to put her down
and the only one on my worst is emily
radakowski i actually do feel like there
weren't a lot of terrible my worst was
kourtney kardashian
and nicki minaj wow yeah
i'm pitting female rappers cardi and
nicki worst and best there wasn't a lot
of terrible amongst like the big
celebrities of course there was always
people who showed up like how you don't
know their names looking bad but um
out of the big ones
only really mrado is a disappointment
it's really bad
um okay let's get into the rest of the
story i do need to pee i didn't even
realize until you know by the way like
we should have peed before i didn't
realize how long this episode was going
to be yeah we'll be fine because
honestly i think getting up will be like
make it make it worse
we just have to like not move our
bottoms okay
continue on
youtube
i go p
and then i'll do the next add and you go
p that's such a good idea okay talk
three two go
today's episode is brought to you by
blue land did you know that an estimate
is
that
estimated by i like how i said i had to
be and then she gets to go okay [ __ ]
did you know that an estimated 5 billion
plastic hand soap and cleaning bottles
are thrown away each year and if that's
not bad enough each bottle can be made
of more than 90 water that's a lose-lose
situation for the planet it's 20 22
people stop wasting water and throwing
out more plastic and get blue lamb's
revolutionary refill cleaning system
instead blueland's idea is simple and
beautiful buy the bottle once refill it
forever no more plastic waste the only
thing you need is to just the only thing
you need to discard is your outdated
idea that eco-friendly products are more
expensive and less effective just fill
blue lens beautiful instagramable
bottles with warm water pop in one of
the hand soap and spray cleaner tablets
and within minutes you have powerful
cleaning products in the most incredible
sense such as iris agave perine lemon
and lavender eucalyptus from their
best-selling cleaning essential oils
from their best-selling clean cleaning
essential kits to their hand soap duo
and plastic free laundry and dishwasher
tablets blueland has something for every
inch of your home and backed by very
popular demand is their toilet cleaner
tablet cleaner get it before it sells
out again they're stunning high quality
forever bottles start at just 10 when
you buy a kit and they are meant to be
used forever with money saving refill
tablets
i have blue land at home i love their
products i think they're so eco-friendly
and they smell really good and they work
really well right now you can get 20 off
your first order when you go to
blueland.com
toast that's 20 off your first order of
any blue land products at blueland.com
toast blueland.com toast i love blue
land i just want to go on record saying
that i was the one who had to pee
and you [ __ ] went right but i'm a new
mama so so like you know when i need
something lickety lickety-split no no
let's do a double no no let's do we're
only on story two so let's get through
story two and three
okay
you have the stories or why don't we
just do a double that's not how it works
but we could no we'll never know we
can't
you're just making it more difficult for
yourself yeah obviously because you went
and i was wondering what to pay sorry it
just seemed like because you were doing
that like whatever
next up some big news came out last
night that's um
just you know big news
the kardashian jenners won in their
black chyna defamation trial no damages
have been awarded to blac chyna in her
defamation trial against the kardashian
jenners china sued chris kim chloe and
kylie for 40 million dollars for loss of
earnings more than 60 million dollars in
future earnings and the jury ultimately
decided no damages but did find chris
kim and kylie acted to protect their own
economic interest
um
what's also so funny is that the verdict
was read yesterday as they were walking
the carpet as they were walking the
carpet and someone asked if the girls
would be attending for the verdict and
they said no they're in new york at some
gala so funny i mean this is not
surprising whatsoever i think if you've
been following the case you know that
angela had like nary
a leg to stand on and
this is not shocking but always great to
you know have a jury roll in your favor
it's never happened to me but i imagine
it feels i wonder if they were sweating
it
i mean i guess that you know when you
go to trial like your lawyer knows
whether or not you have like a chance of
winning and i'm sure their lawyers told
them like based on all the evidence
they've seen the discovery like there's
not a high chance yeah but anything can
happen but what would have happened if
they hadn't wrapped the trial like and
yesterday they were like in court again
doing
interviews and stuff like witness
testimony and stuff like and the met
gala yeah noah that's a good question or
i wonder if like when you're going to
trial if you could be like i need this
day off like going to the gala yeah i
mean trials don't go on on the weekends
right but the mecca was on a monday
right so they could have been in court
all day but they weren't but they
weren't also you guys are not getting
pulled over there's a siren outside our
window yeah and they're just excited
that um the kardashians won their legal
battle justice prevailed
justice has been served okay are you
ready for our next storm we also need to
talk about um how everyone was a twitter
about the fact that taylor swift might
have been performing last night yeah
though she didn't um everyone was
tracking her jet she did land in new
york but at the time that she landed
like
it was people taking all day to get
ready for them she could have been
getting ready on the job right but
usually i feel like if she were going
she would have done like the the works
um she came to new york and then they
went they took off to london uh so that
was disappointing i really did think she
was gonna be making a surprise
performance me too but her film her
short film all too well will screen at
new york's tribeca film festival oh how
cool taylor swift's latest directorial
venture has landed her an invite to new
york's tribeca film festival on monday
the decorated film festival unveiled the
lineup for its 2022 talks and reunion
series and swift's name on the list may
be a surprise to some
she will screen all too well the short
film and discuss the process of bringing
the 13-minute tracks backstory to
fruition titled the conversation with
taylor swift the event will take place
at the beacon theater in front of a live
audience on june 11th at 3 p.m you
should try and snag yourself a ticket
you know what
um the vegan theater is owned by madison
square garden which is where i'm
performing on thursday tickets available
girlsnojob.comtour so i feel like you
know
maybe when i get there on thursday i'm
just gonna start asking around if anyone
can get me a ticket yeah i do feel like
as someone who has performed at the
beacon theater right there should be an
in for like beacon theaters who want to
artists who want to support other beacon
theater artists no i completely agree
we're because we're a small but niche
and powerful community of people who
performed at the vegan theater and now
it's nice that taylor is going to join
our club you know we meet up every month
yeah and now it would be good
i mean the short film is so darn good
that it
yeah but i just assumed tribeca film
festival was for movies like that were
over an hour and for movies that were
bad
that too no but it will be in the shorts
documentary right right no i love love
love of love also i'm sure it's just
like this conversation they're just like
using taylor's influence obviously to
get people out like hype for their
little festival yeah little
tiny tiny small festival um any ounce of
taylor i'll get but this does mean i
feel like she won't be moving out of the
red era until at least june 11th whereas
like any day now i could wait for her to
drop like 1989 taylor's version but if
she's doing
something all too well related in june
she doesn't mix eras like that means
we're still in the red tv era and next
is confirmed 1980 no oh
just a thought
okay i think it'll be till october till
we get the next one she loves an october
drop she also loves a december drop
because that's her birthday
but she did november for red because red
is an autumnal album it's sad girl
autumn i'm calling on october for the
next drop
i don't know a little bit a whole year
almost since read that's insane because
then then this is going to be a six year
process because i'm also ready for new
taylor music like forgot that's an
option too oh hey taylor watch out she's
on one she's no i'm pissed she's losing
her patience and as long as i'm
complaining about things from people
that i love just really quickly i was
thinking last night before going to bed
how like we have to watch kardashians
this week and it's going to be from snl
still like i'm like low-key annoyed they
said that there was gonna be faster
turnaround and the fact that like
there's so much happening
so much happened last night and when i
go to watch kardashians it's gonna be
like travis and kyle again travis and
kylie travis and courtney getting
engaged like [ __ ] i have moved on like
i'm just as long as i'm complaining
about people i stand and respect taylor
move it along kardashian's also move it
along yeah
i'm sorry that you're going through that
i said what i said
damn
damn anyways big news for taylor in the
film space and the gang and the gang
next up some exciting podcasting news is
there anything you want to say before
the podcasting news i do i have a lot to
say so take your time you know could be
number one
could be number two
this podcast is brought to you by better
help people don't always realize that
physical symptoms like headaches teeth
grinding and even digestive issues can
be indicators of stress and let's not
forget about doom scrolling sleeping too
little sleeping too much under eating
and overeating i mean stress is a daily
thing and it is extremely real i know
that quality both claudia and i have
dealt with stress and anxiety and better
help is an amazing resource to better
yourself and your mental health it is so
important because stress shows up in all
kinds of ways and in a world that's
telling you to do more sleep less and
grind all the time here's your reminder
to take care of yourself do less and
maybe try some therapy yes here is your
reminder this is your sign if you have
been looking for one claudia and i have
been using better help for a very long
time now and we could not recommend it
more highly it is such a great resource
it is so accessible they have amazing
healthcare professionals and it's just
the thing you need if you are looking to
better your mental health which you know
in these trying times is so important
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to
love that it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy give it a try and see
if online therapy can help lower your
stress
morning toast listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
toast that's a b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash toast gorgeous sign up
better your mental health how are you
feeling i'm good i don't have time to
button my pants was fun or wash your
hands no of course not okay yeah plus
the sink in that bathroom is not good i
like this content never sleeps yeah just
ethan's far my god yeah take your time
next up a little podcast news ooh laguna
beach rewatch podcast will be hosted by
christina chris christina cavallari
kristin cavallari and stephen coletti
laguna beach stands we'll get a dose of
tea from stars kristen and steven in the
first ever rewatch podcast for the fan
favorite reality tv show from the 2000s
called back to the beach with kristen
and steven i do think they could have
chosen a better name to premiere this
summer comes from broadcast production
company deer media which is ordered 40
episodes across two seasons
everyone knows laguna beach the real
orange county aired for three seasons on
mtv is that what it was called yes
because it was
it was the follow-up to the oc so it was
laguna beach the real orange county just
like this just like the real housewives
yes the real desperate housewives
i never put that together the show
followed the lives of eight precocious
teenagers growing up in the coastal
california town including the tumultuous
on and off romance between kristen and
steven you can watch the whole show on
paramount plus just learn that so i love
this for dear media i love this for dear
media this is now a new trend they've
done it for the oc they've done it for
the office and now they're doing it
they're doing it for twilight which
doesn't bother me as much who's the host
alice
and i don't know some girl ashley green
is doing it yeah okay i like that so i
actually hate this trend i like the beat
i hate this trend like i think it's so
lame and boring and like living in the
past even the oc i'm like who cares um
people seem to like it so i'm on my own
but i don't hate it when with the
twilight thing i just have to say people
love office ladies it's like the number
one podcast always they're constantly
beating us in the charts constantly it's
like the number one comedy podcast most
of the time and i do think that's
inspired a lot of other people which i
think is cool um
it's a lot of homework and listening and
watching youtube to watch the episode
and then listen to the podcast and like
i love the oc but this is a proven
format like people [ __ ] love it it's
a proven format so i think this is a
great
next show to do it with i think chris
and steven will be really good i'm
surprised kristen doesn't already have a
podcast she's like so personable and
she's a talker also maybe this might
like spark a romantic flame between the
two yeah what is steven up to these days
i don't know maybe like he's probably
married yeah i mean he's definitely
desperate enough to do a podcast so i
don't think
that he is like they really could get
back together
that would be crazy if like that's how
it ended steven colletti wife it would
be very jlo and ben affleck you know
very noticeably absent last night yes
noticeably yes she must have been really
busy because she loves an event an event
and a big one like that yeah totally
noticeably absent was that the fifth and
final story you know it was four i was
hoping i could just get away with it
because um like usually i picked five
before the show but i realized i had
only picked four and i mean that's okay
this episode is literally during the
summer breaks and stuff i was looking
for a fifth but it just like it didn't
happen for me that's totally i was
hoping like no one would notice if we
just did four sorry i didn't mean to
blow up your spot but no i guess the
fifth story would be that the redheads
is dropping this week and it's never too
late to become a redhead no i think the
actual story would be that i'm
performing at madison square garden on
thursday tickets available at girls no
job.com tour the final show of this
comedy tour they're not like other girls
tour there are a few seats available but
it's almost sold out which is just like
so crazy um and it's gonna be like a
toaster extravaganza it's gonna be
jackie's first show it's gonna be
amazing i know people are flying in for
it you're not going to want to miss this
is basically like toast headquarters
like everyone's coming to town it's
going to be toast chella it's toast
chella and we haven't had one in a while
not since the beginning i'm really
excited for a toasty night me too it's
going to be sickening and you don't want
to miss it like and that's you're going
to
what's that what's the um the website
that you can get tickets i can't
remember growth.com tour right right
thank you so much it's hard to remember
girlwithnojob.comtour
um and that is our show that was our
mecca extravaganza sorry for the chaos
at the end like i just didn't expect it
to take so long no not at all how long
has it been does anyone know
an hour and a half okay that's not that
bad i have no no um well thank you guys
so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennial morning show are we
delivering the past stories that you
need to know everybody through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so it's spotify
itunes stitch or public radio i haven't
read a cat box all the places so
whenever you listen to podcasts find out
some morning toast and leave advice to
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are have an amazing day we'll
see you back tomorrow with jackie for
our final episode of the week for hump
day
can't wait goodbye goodbye
[Music]
you